will uh dogecoin take over the world
twitter questions you know i don't i
don't follow the the different coins
that much so i don't i i hear about
dogecoin and you know i've kind of
followed the story of it so the
interesting aspect of deutsche coin
is it
so
in contrast to like uh bitcoin and
ethereum which are these
serious
implementations the cryptocurrency that
seek to solve some of the problems that
we're talking about with smart contracts
and
and uh resist the the the banks and all
those kinds of things
deutsche coin operates more in the space
of memes and humor
still doing some of them
similar things and it presents to the
world sort of a question of
whether
memes
whether humor
whether narrative
will go a long way
in the future
like
much farther than some kind of boring
old
uh grounded technologies
whether we'll be playing in the space of
fun
like once we build a base
of comfort and stability
and like a robust system where everyone
has shelter everyone has
uh
food
and the basic needs covered are we going
to then operate in the space of fun
that's that's why i think about deutsche
coin because it seems like fun
spreads faster
than anything else fun of different
kinds and that could be bad fun and they
could be good fun yeah and so it's it's
a battle of of good fun it goes viral
very very quickly
when you when you if you post something
that people find fun to yeah and that's
what deutsche represents so there's like
so bitcoin represents like financial
uh
like
serious financial instruments yeah and
then deutsche represents fun
and it's interesting to watch the battle
go on on the internet to see which wins
this is also like open question to me of
what is the internet
because
[Music]
fun seems to prevail on the internet
and is that a fundamental property of
the internet moving forward when you
look 100 years out or is this a
temporary thing
that was true at the birth of the
internet and it's just true for a couple
of decades until it fades away and and
the adults take over and become serious
again well i think the adults took over
initially and then
it was later on that people started
using it for fun frivolous things like
memes
and that's i think that's pretty much
unstoppable
you know
yeah
because even people who are very serious
uh
you know enjoy um
sending around a funny picture or
something that amuses them
yeah i i personally think
we spoke about world war ii i think
memes will save the world and prevent
all future wars
you